this is an annual foreign policy Forum
where Russia's president holds the
keynote speech a chance for him to vent
at length on one of his favorite themes
the imminent end to Western dominance
the collapse of the USSR destroyed the
equilibrium of the world order because
the West considered itself the winner
now the cultural domination of the West
is coming to an end we're facing a
historic Milestone ahead of us is the
most crucial and unpredictable decade
since the end of World War II
[Music]
between NATO and Russia he claimed he'd
never mentioned using nuclear weapons
and accused Western nations of talking
up the nuclear threat in order to
alienate Russia from its allies with a
special aside for Liz truss
the ex-priminister of the UK she said it
directly in her conversation with a
representative of the media she said the
UK is a nuclear power and the pm has it
in its mandate the possible use of
nuclear weapons I'm not quoting her but
it's close to her text and she said
she's prepared to do that and no one
responded in any way well she just made
a mistake she was just a bit out of it
from the Pentagon an attempt to cool
concerns around Russia's nuclear drills
something we continue to watch uh and uh
we haven't seen anything that caused us
to believe at this point that that is
some kind of cover I do
Anita is holding its own nuclear
exercises too Vladimir Putin's tone on
the nuclear issue was more measured than
it has been but he is sticking to his
claim that Ukraine is preparing a dirty
bomb and plans to lay the blame on
Russia for it a claim that Keith flatly
denies
the British foreign secretary called
Putin's message unclear untrue and
unedifying but there is a captive
audience for all this in Russia and
Beyond and Central America and in Africa
a Russian flag is everywhere you have
peoples who loves and who supports
Russia
music to the ears of a man determined to
prove he is not as isolated as the West
might hope dynamagne Sky News Moscow